I am Alina pants and I am a scientist at
the Sanger Institute I specialize in
cell and molecular biology and use these
skills to study malaria in simple terms
malaria is a debilitating disease that
affects the tropical world and beyond it
is caused by a single-cell parasite
transmitted from person to person by
mosquitoes the malaria parasite has a
complex life cycle and in the human host
goes through several stages in the lab I
concentrate on the blood life cycle
malaria parasites are infectious
organisms so in order to work with them
we need a special lab these are cl3
or containment level 3 laboratories the
purpose of the cl3 is to protect the
workers outside as well as those inside
working with the infectious organism for
this we need protective clothing in the
form of a lab coat and gloves
we culture the parasite in plastic
flasks and petri dishes using blood from
the NHS Blood and transfusion center
malaria parasites need special
conditions to grow in the lab a specific
mix of gas a 37 degree environment to
mimic the body temperature and a fresh
supply of blood in a cl3 we work in
hoods this serves to protect the worker
from the parasite and also to protect
the cultures from any contaminating
agents that might be in the environment
in the hood we have bleach containers to
dispose of anything that has been in
contact with the parasite
we take a sample of the culture we put
it on a slide and smear it let it dry
then the slide needs to be fixed and
stained with ginza which is a
blue-collar n't that will allow us to
see the red blood cells and the
parasites on a microscope on the
microscope what we look for is the
stages of the parasite that are present
in the culture so we see the red blood
cells in light blue and within the red
blood cells we can see darker purple
--is-- forms of the parasite the very
small ones are rings that will then grow
into bigger parasites called trophozoite
and these will start multiplying and
forming a shield this is the mature form
of the parasite that will burst out of
the red blood cell and invade new cells
we genetically modified a parasite to
knock out or modify certain genes in
order to assess whether these are
involved in the disease we also
introduce fluorescent proteins into the
parasite to be able to follow it
throughout the infection and assess its
ability to invade particular red blood
cells
I was always fascinated by the natural
world and I always wanted to understand
how things work to be able to see the
cells and the parasites and work on
their interactions that is very exciting
[Applause]
[Music]